all right so CT overpass just got harder
arguably the best piece of utility the
rant Molly Isn't a thing anymore you see
in CS go the super meta thing to do was
to throw this rant Molly at the
beginning of every single round that
would stop the teams as they tried to
run into playground and they'd have to
throw a smoke to extinguish it and to
make it out now you can still rant Molly
in CS2 and I'm gonna show you how it's
just not nearly as good you're gonna
find this little gray splotchy thing on
the wall and you're just gonna run
forward and jump behind now that Molly
is gonna land and it's gonna get full
coverage the problem is
[Music]
slow so what you're going to want to do
instead is throw this name you're gonna
hop up onto this garbage can and you're
literally just going to jump and you're
going to throw the Nave like that and
it's gonna explode and it's gonna hit
anyone running out of tram this nade's
gonna hit any of the t's running out of
ramp into playground and do a ton
of damage so throw the next time you
play overpass